all right
well
here we go
so yeah this is a bit different than
what i would normally be doing on a
saturday usually saturday is reserved
for
my scripted edited the basically the the
best work that i have you can go to
break room of geeks for my unscripted
ramblings most of them anyways
but uh this time
i'm turning it into a live stream
because i had made the decision
that i was going to react
to
a nearly seven-year-old video
in which i had previously made an
argument against
the idea of having a woman cast as the
doctor
now initially i thought i was just going
to make it like any other video i'd film
myself you know reacting to it i'd put
it together in um
you know in the editing but the thing
was i didn't like the idea
that it would bring into question
whether or not i had like really overly
thought about it if i had like prepared
stuff or if through the magic of editing
i had um sort of
tried to put myself in the best light
possible or anything like that i didn't
want that to be at
issue
so that's why i'm doing it live
oh boy
so
a couple of things about this
firstly though i see we have a decent
amount of people in the chat already and
i'm really excited by that unlike my
normal bi-weekly tuesday live streams
i'm not going to be paying attention to
the chat because i don't want the chat
to overrun this live stream i want this
mainly to be
me reacting to the old video
so
unlike other times i will only be
responding to super chats i'm not going
to respond to those as they come up i'm
actually going to save that until
the end when i'm done we will sort of
decompress and wrap up and at that time
i will address any super chats comments
questions or anything um sent there
so
keep that in mind that i am not actively
watching the chat the other thing i
suppose as a preface on all of this is
that
i have i don't know the last time i
re-watched this i didn't re-watch this
in prep
of
doing this
like i know some creators say oh i never
rewatch my old stuff except you know i
do
i absolutely do sometimes but it's been
a long time since i've rewatched this
probably at a guess
three or four years
um so i generally remember what i said
but i don't remember my exact words for
most of this
and this is also gonna be uh a look back
in time in a lot of ways not just on my
opinion
but of kind of who i was because
this was made about
almost four years ahead of when i came
out as genderfluid on this channel
and i was still presenting mail i was
still trying to make a green screen
effect work which i actually think i
could
pull off now i think i've got that
figured out but at the time i didn't
really know what is what i was doing the
sound quality is probably gonna be crap
but
the one other thing i'll say is that uh
annoyingly to me like while i am glad
that this video is not in my top five
most views it is number six
uh and it's actually the oldest video in
like my top 30 most views so this thing
has persisted
for a while and i don't love that and
that's actually part of the reason why i
wanted to address it and talk about it
since
it is probably
really out of date
we'll see i've said in the past that my
thoughts have changed but given that
it's so long since i last reviewed what
those thoughts were
maybe it's time that uh i do that
so
oh boy so uh right off the bat
i think this is actually one of the
better times that the green screen like
i never
figured out how to properly adjust the
green screen in the editor at least not
way back then um i i do know how to do
it now but uh
there's the green screen and i did
the sound is going to be weird and
echoey because i did
nothing
about the fact that i was recording this
in a very open room at the time but
there's the old hoodie i hadn't even
adopted the hat yet that's how old this
video is i wasn't even doing the flat
cap yet
but uh yeah there's me
um
well before i was
i was putting myself out there as uh as
who i am but you know what that's enough
delay let's get going on this
before i even get started if you are not
caught up to the end of series eight of
doctor who you need to go away right now
just turn this off and walk away
okay
well at least i gave a
spoiler warning
on that that's uh that's helpful
uh
i didn't have an opening credit sequence
yet so this all right i should explain
this
uh right off the bat
so this
image is a holdover from back when
council of geeks was originally a series
of scripted shorts
in which i played one of three
characters the other two being played by
nicole bradford um on the left and
nathan colpitz in the center um who i
actually saw earlier today at the
farmers market uh so that's that's what
this setup is and i didn't have um
artwork commissioned yet i i
it's still the same
music though i've always had the same uh
theme music
but yeah that's who those folks are um
nicole uh moved way way away a lot uh a
while back but i still see nathan on
occasion um he's hard to reach unless i
see him at the farmers market though
he's never on social media okay anyways
everybody left's caught up right good
because i've been wanting to talk about
this actually since even before it was
announced that peter capaldi was going
to be the 12th doctor
okay so i know i said about seven years
ago but that should give you the time
frame i made this
um
basically right after the missy reveal
that's largely what this is in response
to so this this was not made in response
to jody's casting this was made actually
even before we knew when capaldi was
going to be leaving so i
very much jumped on uh poo-pooing this
idea before a lot of people thought it
was even likely to happen
i i got on the ground floor
go me
hmm i want to talk about the possibility
of the doctor becoming female and
specifically why i think that may not be
a great idea now i'm really hoping
people are going to stick with me as i
explain this because i'm not just saying
oh doctor should always be a man
i want to explain this i've got reasons
for feeling this way and given what just
went on in terms of the master now
becoming missy i think i really need to
talk about it because i feel like we
might as well start a clock for when
they're eventually going to give us a
female doctor
okay so i was i was right about that but
i
oh
i think you can tell
right off the bat that i'm already kind
of preemptively being defensive like i
like i somehow know in the back of my
mind
that um
that i i'm i'm gonna get accused of just
being misogynistic
and you can tell from the way i am sort
of being like okay now like understand
why i'm doing this understand why i uh
why i want to talk about this and that
i've wanted to talk about for a while as
if
that would make it okay if i end up
saying something really stupid which
again i don't remember if i do
or not
i am going to check the chat really
quick rp i know i know the sound quality
is
bad
but uh are folks uh hearing it okay when
when i uh play the video i am just gonna
check the chat on that real quick
oh boy
skinny egg with boring glasses says what
thanks gozer thanks a a whole bunch for
that
oh boy
oh geez
a lot more people in the chat now that
that makes me nervous how many folks are
watching me humiliate myself
whoo
all right can hear the videos was okay
good i thought i balanced it well but i
get paranoid so we'll keep going i know
there are a lot of people out there who
want a female doctor but what part of
what bothers me and part of the reason i
need to make this video is most the
people who are arguing oh the doctor
should be a female seem to have as the
heart of their argument because it's
time
oh boy
that
so i think this is at this if i remember
correctly is going to be at the heart of
what has aged really really badly about
this is that i'm going to kind of demand
that there be a reason to make this
change and that you can't just do it and
well
you can no matter what you think about
jody's era or uh or chivnall
yes you can just do it you do not have
to justify the existence of a woman
oh boy that oh
not a fully developed reason i'm not
saying it's a completely invalid one i'm
not saying that's not part of the
conversation but for a kid that's been
around this long you've got to have more
reason than that to change something so
fundamentally because it's got things
that it's got to overcome and it's got
issues that it's got to deal with and
that's mainly what i'm going to talk
about here
okay so
there i am trying to trying to frame it
as carefully as possible because you
like
at least
to old me's partial credit at least i
acknowledge that the fact that because
it's time
is at least in the conversation
i still kind of dismiss it out of hand
as not being a fully valid reason but at
least i acknowledge that it's not an
invalid consideration i just reject it
as being the primary one which
uh that's
that's that's not great
um
and if i remember how this goes i'm
gonna end up laying out a bunch of
things that i'm not i'm gonna say
aren't necessarily reasons to never do
it but things that i expect to be
addressed if this ever happened i don't
think any of them were and in hindsight
i don't care
about any of this oh boy i'm not
actually saying that the doctor should
never be female or that a female doctor
could never work i actually would be
very happy to see a female doctor work
i've said a lot in various videos that
one of my favorite things is to be
proven wrong
okay that hasn't changed
that that about me is still true i know
some people like really think i i may
say a lot but i never want to be right
when i say i don't think something will
work or be good so that hasn't changed
about me i love seeing something that i
don't think is going to work and just
watching it succeed i love that i had
that happen to me a few times in series
8 of doctor who robot of sherwood was a
great example i don't like the
historical set episodes where he meets a
famous figure but that was a fantastic
episode i loved it i went in thinking i
was gonna hate it so i like it when that
happens when someone can take something
that shouldn't work and makes it work
again like it's funny that at the time i
was saying all these things
assuming that they that it would make
whatever i was gonna say next okay
and so like i had enough self self
awareness to understand that i needed to
cushion
uh the nonsense that i was gonna be
spewing but um
not enough self awareness to realize oh
actually maybe this isn't something i
need to even put out in the world in the
first place
what i don't want to see happen is i
don't want to see the people behind
doctor who caving to pressure from this
growing population that seems to have a
basic argument of well why not well i'm
going to tell you why not
not why not but why we can't just barrel
ahead blindly into this idea
oh
wow
okay
i
i did not remember that i basically said
flat out i don't want them caving to
pressure
that oh geez
like i suppose the one thing i'll say in
my defense is keep in mind i wasn't
like circulating among
the not my doctor types of who tubers
it's not like i abandoned them when they
got toxic i actually never watched any
of them so
i don't think i realized that at that
point in time that was already a common
um kind of dog whistle phrase you know
don't just cave into pressure cause
social justice worries said you need to
do i know i didn't say social justice
words but it's that sentiment and
hearing that come out of my mouth
oh god
no honey
no
oh god
okay this is this is this is actually as
of right now a little worse
than i remember it being
oh god there's two major hurdles that
have got to be overcome if the doctor is
ever to become a female one is more or
less logistical one is philosophical i'm
going to start with the logistical
problems
so
again we'll see if memory serves me
correctly i i remember
last time i watched thinking my
philosophical argument was at least more
interesting because the logistical
especially at this point in time
when like i've made videos talk about
how i hate the timeless child twist
absolutely but we do not need to wreck
on it and we do not need to deal with
the logistics of it once chidnal's gone
whoever is the show writer next just
ignore it
so like doctor who as much as people
talk about the canon of the show doctor
who has such a flexible inconsistent
cannon if something doesn't work just
don't talk about it just ignore it
why do you think the show has never
properly dealt with the idea that the
doctor is half human
you know that showed up in the in the
palm again tv movie just ignore it if it
doesn't fit ignore it so the fact that
i'm about to demand
that i'm about to give uh reasons as to
why i'm demanding a logistical
answer like
all of it's going to be nonsense because
doctor who does not need to be
airtight it's not airtight it will never
be airtight it is too it's been going on
too long and it's too sprawling
so i i'm already
grimacing at the fact that i'm even
about to lay out this nonsense now in
talking about the logistics i'm gonna
have to go into a lot of history and a
lot of backstory even going back into
the classic era there's a lot we still
don't know about regeneration in terms
of how exactly it works and what time
works can or can't control about their
new bodies there seems to be a very
limited degree of control over certain
aspects for example riversong was
concentrating on a dress size when she
regenerated and let's kill hitler in
utopia derek jacoby as the master made
it clear that he wanted to become
younger as a reflection of the doctor so
him becoming john sim a visibly
physically younger character also seems
to have been a conscious choice but
there's all sorts of stuff that is
clearly just left up basically to chance
things like hair and liver color should
have been kidney but
so the this is another thing that i i
suspect is part of the reason why this
video
has persisted to the degree that it has
is
in my defense quote unquote i did do
some leg work i did like look into the
history of
um regeneration and all that except that
what's funny is
i'm i'm in the process of pointing out
the inconsistencies and how little we
know about it
as if that
is isn't just a natural outcropping of
the fact that the show is never really
cared consistently how it works and that
the idea that i'm not like now demanding
like well here's where i'm about to if i
remember correctly i'm about to start
doing well out of these things that we
do know we have to stay consistent oh
for god's sake
oh
i this this this is this is more painful
than i thought it was going to be
and the problem is we don't really know
what is something that they have control
over what's something they don't have
control over now i do need to touch on
the one sort of anomalous regeneration
really quickly and that was romana's
because the thing is she comes in and
basically seems to try on several bodies
and before deciding on one and seem to
have absolute complete control over the
body that she does in fact end up
choosing the thing is though we don't
know the circumstances of that
regeneration we never have it may in
fact have been a completely voluntary
regeneration and that may have been what
gave her that degree of control as
opposed to all the other regenerations
we've seen which have been to prevent
someone from dying and they were more
sort of last-minute desperation in dire
circumstances so maybe in a commerce
situation doing it completely
voluntarily maybe they're granted
further control i mean
all right so like
that's a lovely bit of head canon
but i'm i'm leaning on it like it's
agreed fact and
it's not there's nothing wrong with that
idea as headcanon because there's plenty
of room in doctor who for head canon
because there's a lot of stuff that
doesn't fit
and again like uh it just annoys me so
much that i even made this like big
here's the logistical reasons as if
doctor who has ever properly followed
logistics it doesn't it never has
and like he and here's the thing here's
where i'm irritated with my past self
while i'll give myself the credit in so
far as i clearly did some research like
to put together an argument as opposed
to just spewing utter nonsense
um
the truth is is that i i went into that
video
already thinking i don't think it's a
good idea for the
doctor to um regenerate into a woman and
then
while i did my research quote unquote i
did my research based around a
conclusion i'd already come to so
you know all of this is taking the
things that i found uh about
regeneration and about other things and
like
coming at it from the angle that best
suited
the point i already decided i was gonna
be making
which is
the classic way to do this wrong some of
my favorite videos are actually ones
where i went in intending to make one
point and then did the leg work for what
i was going to be talking about and
realized no actually i can't make the
point i thought i was going to make i'm
going to have to make a completely
different point uh and that is not what
happened here
the real answer why roman did that is
because douglas adams was the script
director at that point and he thought it
would be funny
oh my god i just acknowledge the fact
that there are flippant ridiculous you
know reasons for these things and that
it maybe it shouldn't be counted anyway
i just openly acknowledge that and yet
i'm still going on about
how we need to be logistically
consistent how did i how how how did i
just acknowledge the fact that you know
what maybe we shouldn't worry about this
anyway and then continue to talk about
all the reasons we should be worried
about this
oh god i think we need to not dwell on
that one too much
maybe not dwell on the whole thing
dude
there's a thought
i can call my old self dude it's okay
let's look back about what we know about
regenerations and about the
regenerations that we got the autofocus
it's going in and out of focus
i'm watching that happen and just it's
driving me nuts because since the
background is green screen the
background's always in focus me
in and out in and out it was an
embarrassingly long time before i sorted
the manual focus on even that old um
camera we've seen i'm about to throw a
whole lot of numbers at you we are on
our 13th physical body for the doctor
we've had seven incarnations of the
master three of her song and two of
romana now what we can also add in is
timeline characters who we've seen
played by more than one actor and are
clearly in different bodies even though
we did not see the actual regeneration
happen that allows us to add in two
wrath salons and four incarnations of
former lord president barussa so if you
haven't been doing the math that's 31
confirmed incarnations of different time
lords why did i just throw all those
numbers at you well because out of those
31 missy is the only one that we've seen
gender swapped
so yeah like
i'm not going to argue that like my
research and my numbers were wrong but i
i am just going to point out that the
fact that i'm even making a deal out of
this
and that i know i know
that i went into
this looking for reasons
to to make a case
but the numbers are so or they were at
the time this is obviously outdated
we've seen a lot more regeneration since
then
that would seem to lean towards gender
being something that they choose to
change as opposed to being a random
factor if gender was just going to be
completely left up to chance we should
have seen more gender swaps up to this
point just by law of averages
so wait am i not going to bring up the
corsair
because yeah missy yes but like
while we never met the corsair that was
made very explicit
i hope i mentioned that that's a big
oversight if i didn't now i will grant
it's possible that maybe gender is a
random factor but it only has say a 1 in
50 chance of swapping from one to the
other i don't think that's the case
though because if we look at missy and
the characterization of missy
the master has really embraced
femininity in a way that i don't think
someone who just randomly just found
themselves in the body of their gender
would do it really seemed like that was
something that that character wanted to
have happen and i wanna
based on what based on what do you say
i love the fact that i start with an
open acknowledgement of
harder data
the fact that it is possible that gender
could be randomized but it's not even
though there's two gender options that
doesn't mean it's a 50 50 that the odds
of that thing swapping are actually
completely different from just being uh
on either one or the other which
is a totally valid thing that like
invalidates all my data points if that's
the case because we don't know the
percentages of anything changing and
then
i immediate so i give a hard data thing
that actually kind of invalidates the
points i'm making and then i bring up
how just how missy behaves like it
doesn't seem to me like that's someone
who just
ended up as a woman by accident like but
based on freaking what
ah
geez dude like it's pos it is there is
absolutely no reason that it could not
have been a random change and missy just
went oh well that happened
heck let's roll with it then there's no
reason why that couldn't be the case
you just oh it doesn't feel like it's
that
yeah yeah
data point of one solid info oh god add
into that what we know about the corsair
which was our original confirmed gender
swap
okay i didn't forget good now the
corsair is a character who we have never
seen but has talked about and mentioned
in the doctor's wife and what the doctor
tells us about the corsair points very
much towards a hedonistic personality
now that's important because a hedonist
someone who is very into all the
pleasures of the world is the kind of
person who would voluntarily swap
genders just so that they could
experience all the pleasures that are
unique to that gender all this put
together to me it really points heavily
towards gender being something that is
chosen and not a random factor
okay so at least bringing up the corsair
um i am
making more of a case beyond just well
it doesn't feel like it because you know
the the description the doctor gave of
the corsair like it was hedonistic and
so like i am at least backing that view
up with something
but
again that's pretty flimsy and like a
lot of what i'm saying is hint is
hinging on
flimsy stuff i'm not gonna say like
non-existent nothing stuff but like
i don't think that supports where you're
going
i'm sure there are some people out there
who are gonna point to matt smith's
initial regeneration where for a hot
second he thought he was a girl but
let's also remember he needed to confirm
that he had legs and ten fingers and
we've never seen a regeneration where
they're missing limbs i think that can
just be attributed to the general
regeneration wonkiness well
there you go with head cannon again
stating it like it's fact like yes
that's possible it's equally possible
that he genuinely thought that he had
changed into a girl because that was a
possible thing that could have happened
like
that's a head canon answer but it's no
more valid than the other option
so it does look like gender is not
random so i i feel like i i built this
around the number of things i was going
to point out as opposed to any of them
being particularly strong i i had hoped
that a propensity of evidence would
somehow make me right even though taken
on an individual basis not uh not great
points the doctor ever is going to
become a woman it can't just be a random
he had no control over yes it can
yes it can so like again here's the
thing i made a case as to why i don't
why i didn't at the time think that the
gender could be a random chance and i
made a
not terrible but not amazing case for
that point
but now i'm taking that as an accepted
thing and moving forward like well since
it is a choice here's now the next set
of things like that
like
it's oh god it's such a bs tactic too
you know the the whole idea of saying
well i've i've made this case
and
let's just assume i'm right because i'm
going to build the next part of my case
on the assumption that i was right about
this first thing that i may not even be
right about
oh jeez like that
that's that's the way
that the nonsense gets bigger it just it
just picks up it builds on itself and by
the time you're done
that got real ridiculous yeah because
you started with something that you made
a case for but didn't didn't proven
controversially and then built upon that
so it just became more and more and more
and more nonsense oh
okay
he's gonna have to choose to become a
woman why is that a problem why can't he
do that well
the problem is he hasn't up to this
point so
what
so
what oh my okay
this this is where i feel like uh where
i was in my own gender journey at that
point in time is really clogging my
brain
because uh at that point i was not yet
considering myself gender fluid at that
point in time i still thought i was a
cisgender male cross-dresser
that's what i thought i was even though
i had been experimenting with women's
clothing since the age of 11 and had
been actively going out in public in
full fem garb and had gotten into
performing both dragon burlesque as a
female presenting person for years at
that point i still thought i was a cis
male cross dresser so the the thing is
the idea that like well
didn't think
you know didn't voluntarily become a
woman at any point prior to this why
would he do it now well
why did i go on hormones
because i came to a better understanding
of myself over time
oh
you you
stupid stupid summer child if you'd
realize where you were going you would
not be you would not be making this
freaking argument
oh god now he wouldn't just change
sure
sure he would like you don't know what's
gone on in his head
even even if we accept that it is
something that has to be chosen that the
doctor changes gender
you don't know what's gone on his head
the past few generations maybe he's been
thinking about it for ages but then
finally had the guts to do it
what was your life like
several years after you made this video
you dingus
and i don't just mean that in a way like
well you didn't decide up there oh he
could never decide it
here's the thing
it's not that the doctor is above sort
of
rash or hasty decisions he certainly
made them
rash or hasty yes because that's the
only reason someone would become another
gender is like oh just
spur the moment oh my god i cannot
believe i said that various points so
the idea of him deciding on a whim that
he's going to become a woman wouldn't
necessarily be out of character but
here's the thing
just the fact that i said the phrase
deciding on a whim to become a woman and
like what phrases like that are have
been used for
against trans people in the years since
god this is embarrassing holy crap i've
left this up
the doctor the 11th doctor we called him
the 11th matt smith was actually in what
he believed was going to be his final
regeneration
we didn't know that at the time we
didn't really find that out until the
war doctor got introduced and then all
that got made
very clear in the time of the doctor
that we found out that matt smith knew
and presumably has always known that he
was in what was supposed to be his last
body
what that means is if he was ever going
to decide oh i should be a woman while i
still have the chance to at least try
that once he needed to have done it
before he was in what he believed was
his last body
okay so again like this is an issue of
me
trying to project the thought process of
any given doctor in any given
regeneration because the thing is even
knowing that he was on his last
regeneration and he would never get a
chance again assuming that it's
something that you choose anyways
um
even if even if we assumed that and he
hadn't chosen to be a woman even up to
his last regeneration
so what
one of the things that can really shake
somebody out of a sense of complacency
and just accepting the way things were
is a new lease on life
at the end of the at the end of the time
of the doctor he literally has a new
lease on life why couldn't that have
changed his perspective and made him
want to try other things later on that
he hadn't thought were gonna be worth
his time or that he hadn't thought he
wanted to do prior to that
like what oh
god
if there was any part of him that had an
inherent desire to be a woman he would
have done that before he ran out of
chances yes he's got a whole new
regeneration cycle with capaldi that for
all we know is is infinite and he can
gone forever but he didn't know that was
going to happen he thought he was done
and even knowing that he never decided
to become a woman
and again just
the the the ignorance of this because
like how many
how many
late transitioners are there at this
point in time
how many people are there who
honestly thought that their days of
active living were over and they hadn't
embraced that side of themselves but
even though they've quote unquote run
out of time or they think they have
they still embrace it later and are
better for it
like what uh what an absurd stance
that's something that you can't just
ignore or gloss over yeah you can't i'm
not saying that he could never decide to
become a woman but it needs to have more
than just he decided on a whim there
needs to be something more fueled by the
character or some sort of compelling
circumstances that are going to drive
that decision
no no i so i
again to give a
trans person's perspective he's
basically saying well why are you trans
tell me the reason why you are trans
no
i am
that's who i am why did the doctor want
to become a woman we're gonna have to
have a good reason for that no we
freaking aren't
oh
what could that reason are those
circumstances be i have absolutely no
idea but i do think they do need to
exist and it can't just be uh because we
feel like it
you know maybe the fact that you
couldn't think of a reason why this
would
why you know how it would go down maybe
is another indication of why they didn't
do it
oh my god moving aside from the
logistical issues we get into the
philosophical debate because i really do
worry that changing the doctor to a
female is going to too drastically and
fundamentally change the dynamics of the
character and how the character is
intended to work
now this makes me nervous
i don't i don't think
i ever make a
the
the doctor has always been male in there
and was intended to be male
end of story argument but like oh god
it's skirting on the border already
the doctor's relationships with people
whether they are his companions or
people that he just runs into has always
been fundamentally paternal in nature
has it though
like
some of them sure
um ecclestone was rose that was
fairly paternal um the second doctor um
towards somebody like uh
like victoria certainly but he didn't
have a particularly paternal
relationship with jamie
the i mean arguably the seventh if you
equate a um
a teacher's student dynamic to a
paternal one but that's that doesn't
have to be
paternal i just i i just say that
i i don't think i back that up either i
just say it
it's always been a paternal relationship
has it
has it though because i i
i don't think it has at times certainly
always
no
no
he's got that protective streak but he's
also a little bit emotionally distant
sort of the classic archetypal father
figure
again not always sometimes yes not
always
and you're saying it like it's always of
course the gender swap version of a
paternal figure is a maternal figure now
but there's a real big difference
between maternal and paternal yes
because
if if the doctor suddenly looks like a
woman she's gonna have to perform
femininity and therefore the dynamic
will change because a woman can't
express
paternal leanings oh
god
because a maternal figure is going to
inherently have a more emotional
connection with those people where
okay i i i don't even have the spoons to
deal with this
incredibly um
oversimplified idea
of masculine versus feminine
roles in a paternal versus maternal
relationship like i don't even think i
properly acknowledge how oversimplified
this is
and
based in
stereotypes and societal expectations
and not necessarily reality as the
paternal fear is more emotionally
distant as the doctor tends to be it's
not that he doesn't have emotions he's
not expressing them outwardly now i'm
not trying to make this a sexist
argument
[Laughter]
uh you're not trying but you still kind
of are
oh god like women always wear their
emotions on their sleeves i'm just
talking about the general natures and
the archetypes of these sorts of
relationships so break the archetype
like that
and of course paternal figures can kind
of run again a bit like the doctor
himself they can be more hands-on and a
little bit more gentle they can be a bit
more gruff and a bit more wired to doing
what i tell you which the doctor has run
that scale maternal figures on the other
hand maternal and motherly tends to be a
bit more rigidly defined than a father
figure father
so what
who says the doctor has to be maternal
what are you
doing
i don't know they seem to have the
freedom to have more room to breathe but
still fit the definition of a paternal
father figure motherly figures it seems
like it's a much narrower definition i'm
afraid they wouldn't be able to do as
much with the character okay look
i i think it is true that in general
this isn't just a maternal paternal
thing in general male characters are
given a lot more leeway to be depicted
in a much vaster number of tropes and
character archetypes etc whereas women
tend to have fewer to work from but
that's a
problem with writing that's not a
problem with people that's like that
that's bad writing that's bad narrative
societal writing trends why are you
projecting as if we have to stick to
that
that's assuming that they even try and
make the character maternal as opposed
to paternal because really what they
should do is keep it paternal because
that's fundamentally what the character
has always been
no he
no
no they have not
ah often not always
but what i'm saying is if we keep the
character consistent and keep that
paternal instinct having a woman express
the paternal tendencies is gonna read
somewhat off it's gonna read in some
ways kind of defective because when you
have female characters and who have
difficulty expressing their emotions
that's not seen as a positive character
trait not that it's necessarily positive
in men but it's expected in men in women
when you have characters that are sort
of more emotionally compressed and
stunted that seem much more as an
outright flaw yes but again that's a
societal and expectation issue that does
not need to restrict the writing and the
options for what a character in a show
can be
like you're pointing out the the
bs context of life
but then accepting it and not
challenging it
and then there's some of the specific
stuff that the doctor tends to do rather
frequently such as he will frequently
let people his potential enemies think
that he is an idiot and that's all very
much playing off expectations because
the standard stereotypical generic
expectation is the man walks into the
situation and takes charge when he
bumbles in and acts like an idiot they
dismiss him well when a woman comes in
and does that
she's not just being a bumbling playing
against expectations first of all
there's no set expectation that she's
going to come in and take charge anyway
so she's not subverting anything by
acting like an idiot
okay again like i feel like i'm zeroing
in on my preferred incarnations of the
doctor a lot of the versions of the
doctor that i like
uh were like that did come in and seem
like idiots four would do that sometimes
two would do that a lot seven did it on
occasion but there are others who don't
really do three
rarely did that three did come in
and like
act like he was already in charge of
everything and eight
i don't i've never come across a
situation where eight intentionally
acted like a [ __ ] so it's just
i i'm taking these qualities that are in
the incarnations that i like more and
projecting them as if that's how all
doctors are and how the doctor should
always be and just
no
just know
when a woman acts in the way that the
doctor has frequently acted to make
himself look stupid she becomes
something a little bit more specific she
becomes a ditz
i mean like okay so here i'm talking
about perceptions and how the
the character would be perceived
differently doing the same things but
doing it as first of all
moving past the fact as i already
pointed out these are not inalienable
things about the character they don't
have to exist in every incarnation and
they haven't existed in every carnation
so even setting that aside if that were
true
why does that become a reason to not do
it why does that not become an
opportunity to deconstruct and comment
on how a woman behaving that way is
perceived differently than a man
behaving that way why can't it become
part of the story
that a woman more emotionally guarded is
not is not
um thought of and
um
and just regarded in the same way that a
man who is emotionally emotionally
guarded is why can't now they didn't
really end up i mean jodie's doctor is
pretty emotionally guarded they didn't
do anything really with that as as yet
but um outside of a couple of scenes but
like i'm i'm just presuming that well
they wouldn't do that or they couldn't
do that or that i i don't i don't think
they did like these are all
opportunities to do new things
you're just arguing to
never evolve
or not step up to the plate step up to a
challenge
what i'm saying is that there's a lot of
stuff that the doctor does that if a
woman were to do just changing that
gender carries over a lot of baggage and
that changed from one to the other
suddenly the dynamic of the character
isn't functioning the way it normally
does or the way it's supposed to
you say supposed to as if every doctor
is the same and they're not fact that
the doctor his first instinct is to
run from danger is another example yes
the doctor will eventually stand up and
take charge but his first instinct when
encountering danger is to run and then
figure it out what's the stereotypical
male action hero he stands and fights
with with fists or a gun or whatever the
doctor doesn't do that again subverting
the expectation when the doctor if he
was to ever become a woman again there's
no expectation that she would be
standing up and fighting with fists and
guns in the first place so running away
it loses that subversion of the of the
stereotypical hero
okay so like
there's a slight point that i'm managing
to make here which is that the doctor is
a um a subversive character
in a lot of ways in terms of the
expectations of a hero especially in
often very action-focused situations
which the doctor frequently will find
themselves in
that the doctor comes at it with
intellect and mischievousness and
runs very readily away from things um as
almost a default like all of those are
yes
um
subversions of the expectation of a
masculine hero
but just because the doctor becomes a
woman you know okay so the same
subversions don't work
but
you can subvert other expectations
honestly the fact that a woman would be
in those situations at all is already an
inherent subversion
with the doctor it's the way he behaves
with
when he was a man when it's a female
doctor the fact that she's even in these
situations is already inherently
subversive
so
that i i get what i'm saying but i'm
wrong
and instead it's now actually more
playing to expectations than rather than
subverting them see changing the gender
is gonna carry a whole lot of baggage
now it's our baggage as viewers to be
fair it's not
thank you for at least saying that much
not the fault of the character it
wouldn't be the fault of the writers
it's the viewers and general audiences
baggage about gender roles and gender
stereotypes
i'm glad i did acknowledge that but at
the same time i'm basically kowtowing to
those expectations and stereotypes being
like well this is what's expected so
can't go too much against the grain
but that baggage exists you can't act
like it doesn't sure you can
sure you can you can you can unpack it
you can lampshade it or you can ignore
it that is an option
and i just worry that that baggage would
sink the show i have a feeling at this
point it's kind of inevitable it's gonna
happen at some point i'm hoping it'll be
a ways down the road and i'm not gonna
suddenly tune out if it's a female
doctor i'll tune in like i said if they
ever do it i wanna see it work one of my
greatest joys was matt smith becoming my
favorite doctor when i oh back when he
was uh it's capaldi now for the record
completely wrote him off at his initial
casting i thought he was going to be
terrible i thought he was going to be a
tenant knockoff and he became my
favorite so i'm completely open to this
working
i'm open-minded really really i am i
promise
i just want to see
the people behind it
when it inevitably happens put the
thought to address all this stuff and
not just do it
because it's time or because there's
this outside pressure or because they
can because if they don't address this
stuff or if they don't at least factor
it in in some way and take this up into
consideration we'll be losing that
classic lovable paternal figure for no
good reason
oh god all right look
i think a point that i was kind of
making but not really is that like
for a long time the kind of subversive
hero that the doctor was there was not a
great deal of
and i think i was bemoaning the idea
that we would lose that particular kind
of subversive hero the thing is though
there's a lot more instances of heroes
like that since then
um
you know whether it be in things you
like or not off the top i had someone
like newt scamander from the fantastic
beasts movies there's there
there are more instances
of characters like heck the way peter
parker's done in the marvel uh
spider-man movies is leaning towards
this more subversive you know not coming
in and taking control but just having to
come at things from a from a different
angle running away regrouping um having
to having to show empathy to figure out
what the heck's going on like that i
feel like that is increasingly common so
we don't have to
crush his you know precious clutch to
our chest and protect
the doctor as a man and as a masculine
hero not to mention the fact that
the previous 12 incarnations don't
vanish
because it becomes a woman even even if
i was right and like we lose this
subverse this subversive male hero
okay
but temporarily
because at some point whether it be the
very next generation or
several down the line eventually the
doctor will be a man again at some point
so
um
i'm treating this character whose
history does not get erased by changing
them into a woman like this precious
thing that must be protected at all
costs and that's i don't even know
where that's coming from
so that's my thoughts on this i've you
know this has been percolating for a
long time and with what happened with
missy i need to get it out there what
are your thoughts on all this i'd be
more than happy to hear them whatever it
is you think whether you think i've got
a point whether you think i'm completely
crazy hopefully you don't just think i'm
sexist i i hope i backed my arguments up
better than that but i mean better than
some
but
not
excellently no
you know whatever it is you think drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned
all right so there's the bits of the
sign off that i i always used uh but
yeah okay
back when there were only two credits to
list
uh
boy
so that um
that's it
uh
there are parts of that
which were worse
than i um
than i thought they were they were gonna
be
um
like
to a limited amount of credit
to me back at the time i i
seemed to at least understand that i i
had to be careful and like i did
construct an argument like i said backed
it up with more than a lot of people
later on and like here's the one thing
that i i feel like was good for me i am
glad that i made that video
so far ahead
of
whittaker's casting now like i was
still
skeptical when whitaker was cast but
even at the time that happened my
position had already softened i think
because i'd had several years to
mull it over and kind of
start to get over myself on the issue
and then by the time she actually
started playing the role i'd kind of
worked through whatever nonsense it was
that spurned me on to make this in the
first place
so i i think it benefited me in that
like i didn't stick my head and pretend
like this was never going to happen
because i i feel like in some way i mean
with the not my doctor crowd uh some of
it is honestly they're just outrage
merchants but in terms of people who
follow them and who buy into it um you
know some of them
i think part of the problem was that
they refused to even engage with the
idea
of a female doctor until it happened
and then they weren't ready for it and
so all of the crap that i started
working through
like two or three years before the
announcement they only just started
working through when the announcement
happened so like
my my softening on this whole thing was
yeah i i'm
i really wonder if i'm gonna still leave
that publicly viewable i may finally
take it down
to have this up so if people want to
know what i thought then now the only
way to see it is
um couched around me commenting on it
now
but
having done all that let's take a look
at the super chats that came up while i
was doing that
so uh first up oh hey angus thank you
evening vera thank you very much um it
is afternoon here for me
uh this video was the first thing i ever
saw of you took me a couple years to
come back
diana bell
thank you i'm glad i did i'm glad you
did too but like i i could not blame
anybody um if after seeing that it put
them off uh watching my stuff uh at the
time or uh or even if you saw it later
on i can't blame you for that
uh sam c thank you very much so happy to
be catching you live for the first time
much love from the philippines thank you
very much
brian l
uh loved you then love you now well
that's good
thanks thanks for sticking around
through the journey
and um diana bell again internalized
heteronormativity is such a drug it
really is
like it's so weird because not only am i
going back and looking at an opinion i
no longer hold but it's coming from a
perspective that is not even anywhere
close to where i am now so
like in some ways i'm reviewing the
things i said in other ways i'm
reviewing the person i was
which is demonstrably not the same
tracy dale
thank you very much oh my it's been
quite a journey yes
yes it has and for the better i
certainly think
and finally aaron oh
thank you so much for the support it's
been quite entertaining seeing how much
you've grown over the years the like i
honestly
like i said i
i did not um prep
i didn't i didn't re-watch this in
preparation for this
stream i really
didn't know
how bad it would get uh at points i
remembered my general points and i think
in my head i'd like well i think i kind
of made a decent argument it's just not
something i would argue for now but
re-watching it
and really sort of confronting
who i was and what i thought and the
case that i made
i'm a bit embarrassed by that now
which i wasn't sure i would be
i i i had thought the optimist in me
thought it was going to be more of a
case of well
here here are the problems but it wasn't
a bad argument no it was a bad argument
it was a bad argument built on moving
forward based on assumptions that i
pretended were fact when they weren't
occasionally acknowledging that but then
it but then plowing forward as if i'm
already right it's
oh
that that was that was a bit that was a
bit
to work through
and to process oh we have had one more
super chat come in thank you microraptor
oh rainbow hearts that is much
appreciated
but we are going to wrap it up there
it's tempting for me to like start
interacting with the chat but if i do
that i'm going to be here forever and
it's already been almost an hour so
thank you for coming with me and joining
me on this
journey
of looking back
and realizing
how much
i am not that person anymore
so thank you very much for joining me
i want you to be well be safe and be
kind
more important than that remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i just run the meetings
whether i'm right or wrong it's still me
oh we one more super chat uh adrenaline
thank you so much this video is going to
be helpful model for so many people who
struggle with the saving face that many
of us cling to when we've already
changed our minds
i i will say on that um just briefly
like yes there is
especially with online punditry it's
seen as weakness to change your position
so
there is this um
praising of pigheadedness and acting
like you've always been right and you've
never been wrong which is stupid
it's stupid
get over yourself it's okay to have been
wrong before
um but yeah we are gonna wrap it up
please remember also that you my friends
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings
whether i'm right or i'm wrong
and uh
thank you to the people who back then
called me out on it and have done so in
the years since
because yeah i deserved that
until next time this council
is adjourned